clean energy without harmful emissions  that's supposed to be the future in  germany wind farms and solar parks are  expanding rapidly  but an increasing number of germans feel  that has a downside  the drawback is that solar power needs a  lot of space  and with wind energy you have wind  turbines all over the place  52 of germans believe the biggest  drawback of the energy transition is the  rising electricity prices  thirteen percent regret the impact on  the countryside  and ten percent believe the technology  involved in renewable energy sources is  not yet advanced enough  but most germans say phasing out nuclear  power and expanding renewables is the  right way to go  i think it's worth it particularly when  you think of future generations  i'm all for it more than 80 percent of  germans agree  with the basic goals of the energy  transition